are there any pitching myths that
screenwriters should be aware of I don't
know if there's any like
Civic myths but I would say the myths
would be
um
believing that like
there's one way to pitch that there's
like a memorized log line you should
have that you go in and like they always
call it like the elevator pitch that
like this is your one shot and that's
totally not true at all and it goes back
to the whole principle of like pitching
is re-pitching it's like
you can repitch the same project dozens
of times it's okay but that idea that
like you're just going to memorize a log
line and you're going to say it once and
that you're going to get this big check
and like that's that's it's done that
that's a total myth and that's totally
not how it works in real life
um and then I would say another myth is
the quote we're buying it in the room
kind of idea that like
um that you go into your meeting you
present it and then like they buy it in
the room and all that it's like I know
there are like a handful of stories out
there of these things sort of happening
um what was the guy's name Joe Esther
house I think uh
you know it's like wrote an idea on a
napkin at a bar while he was hammered
and like you know made Millions off it
and it's like it's not quite really how
it worked the agent was out there to get
the next script of his because his
previous work was so successful they
didn't care what he put the job that
executive or agent or whomever did the
deal with him had was to basically like
write a check whatever he says and just
get something in writing that that's the
objective you know it's like
those I think kind of fall into myths
about how things work was this for Basic
Instinct I know Basic Instinct was his
original like that he he got so much
success for but then his like ladder
work
um I don't I don't know all the films
right right but it's like there was a
series of films that got made uh uh
after that and everyone was hoping to
get the cash cow Basic Instinct because
it was such a big success at the time I
don't know what 90 91 something like
that uh so like early 90s there were a
lot of those movies floating out there
big checks he's one of those very few
screenwriters
who had
that much control and that much clout
and
I don't know if he's in you know an
everyday you know a name that everybody
knows per se Even in our industry but
like there's quite a few people who know
his name over other screenwriters let's
say sure but those are rare those would
be your myths right it doesn't work like
that
never certainly I've never seen it
happen
well here's one myth identify an
untapped or underserved Market that is a
myth of
uh
uh this belief that because it's never
been seen before people therefore will
want to see it and
that's not true at all it's um
I have seen some wacky projects
presented as opportunities that were
just like there's no audience for this
and it doesn't fit anywhere it's like
it's it's you're trying to pitch or
present
um a character or a story that is uh I'm
not saying not relevant to very small
Circles of people but it's like it's so
limited it's just not gonna reach the
like viability of funding
if you want to make it go for it but you
got to find alternative sources for the
revenue but like just going in and
waving a script or a project and saying
it's never been seen before therefore
it's a ticket to an opportunity it's not
it's like it's got to fit into those
kind of core buckets and genres
why are fewer movies made for people
over age 55 because they buy less
generally they tend to not be
people who are will call them elderly I
guess it was still the politically
correct term now it's uh uh it's if
you're in that category of age you are
less likely to be buying or consuming
stuff products at the same rate somebody
who's in their 30s or their 20s would be
if you're talking theater tickets
older audiences don't go to the theater
nearly as often as younger audiences if
you're talking TV content they don't
watch nearly as much television as
younger audiences if you're talking
subscription VOD platforms they're not
as likely to be having six seven
subscription VOD platforms uh that
they're they're popping back and forth
between
um
as a result there's just fewer content
that is directed towards older audiences
and produced for them or the way you do
it is you find content that just
generally speaks to a larger demographic
of people that can be viewed there now
there are a couple of examples Colombo
Murder She Wrote uh was the the lawyer
show and they've done reboots of some of
these too
um
so there are and there's Acorn TV it's a
really good svod platform it was bought
by AMC networks and that's its real
Target demo is is that sort of like
middle aged to slightly older female
audience that's going to watch cozy
Mysteries like Miss Marple and you know
uh Agatha raisin and you know we did a
bunch of Doc Martin uh programs with
them and we did a few other uh uh shows
with them back with my previous company
so um there are outlets for them but
they're not nearly as many as younger
audiences
like I think it's that goes into one of
those things like myths it's it's just
because there's not content for older
audiences doesn't mean like well I'm
gonna write you know a movie that's
aimed at them because no one's doing it
and it's sort of a thing of like there's
a reason why there's not as much
produced for them
myth number two pitching is an art
yeah it's it's there's this belief that
um I think people have this belief about
a lot of things that like there's only
some people that can do it and they do
it well and it's like I really genuinely
don't believe that I think that there's
not one way to pitch I think what's
critical is that you pitch the way you
want to pitch
um it's not an art form in the sense of
like somebody is just brilliantly
skilled at it I mean obviously there are
people more comfortable walking into a
room and talking than others but your
ability to learn how to do it your
ability to improve your capability of
doing it your ability to present
yourself your ideas in a professional
way and be able to make a business case
for why your script or why your projects
should be taken seriously anybody can
learn this stuff
not many people take the time to learn
it they're easy to it's very easy just
to say you know somebody doesn't know
what they're talking about if they're
like presenting this kind of concept but
it's like the truth is you can teach
yourself how to do this you can teach
yourself how to be professional and how
to talk the talk walk the walk Etc
when people talk about pitching a
project are they talking about a big
Hollywood studio project or an
independent film Project like how are
they different and how would the
pitching be different
so
um
for somebody new to the industry
you're not gonna be able to go to
Paramount or Warner Brothers and just
like get on the lot and get to a top
executive and pitch
um there there's literally walls around
them so you're not going to get in uh
but uh if so if you're starting out you
would be working more with independent
Distributors production companies and
they are much more accessible and they
are producing way more content than the
studios are actually producing
at the studio level the way they work is
if you ever go to a lot
um
there's all these like random buildings
there's obviously the big sound stages
and then there's like the corporate
Executive offices but then there's all
these like random offices around the
place and those are production companies
generally contracted by the studio
to just essentially be a filter for the
studio to acquire content to develop
content specifically to go into the
studio machine
so again you're not pitching to the
studio you're pitching to that
production company that is in the sphere
of the studio we'll say
but how is it really different in truth
it's really not it's the numbers on
paper
can be sizably different but um
you know it's it's what things cost can
be different but as far as like being
able to pitch a genre
that is constantly in need being able to
pitch a story that fits that genre well
and being able to pitch a story that
fits that genre that is also
economically feasible and realistic to
produce
it's kind of the same across the board
now it's really hard to go in as
somebody who doesn't have a track record
and do that at the studio level for
multi-million dollar films but you have
a really good opportunity to do it at
the independent level and if you do it
consistently at the independent level
you can work your way up that's why I
really
present a lot of these ideas to help
people kind of start careers because
it's a long long tail game it's not
something that happens overnight and it
is something that you build over a long
period of consistent habits and good
work
and it's not something that happens
right out of film School certainly not
uh
it's it's you just it's it's not that
you know film schools don't teach
students like really good practical
skills and some film schools have
amazing programs that get students right
into Studios or internships Etc but you
need real world working experience and I
can take time to get and it's it's
realizing some of those ideas that you
get at Film School
that you just want to rush out there and
sort of Take On The World so to speak
which is amazing to have the passion but
being able to actually say okay now in
the real world how does this process
really work and it goes back to what are
the core genres what is what does
Hollywood need to function it's a giant
industry it's it's worth you know it's
it's multi-multi-multi billions of
dollars transacting it's it's you've got
to be able to help that machine function
and you've got to be useful within it of
the three books that you've written
Which chapter do you wish you'd had
advice on when you started in this
industry
that is an awesome question
um
I think
the most critical thing that I put in
all I put them in all three books that's
that's kind of how strongly I feel about
it it's realizing that very it's it's
two things it's realizing it's not
script to screen
it's the reverse of that it's you start
at the end which is what do people want
to watch and you work your way backwards
all through the process
what do people want to watch what genres
do they need how much does it need to
cost what is an IP that works and then
it goes back to okay who's going to
write it it's that process
and then realizing what distribution
actually was and how it actually worked
as a business because there's not many
of us in the distribution world it's a
pretty small group of people and a
pretty small handful of companies that
really work in it
um
but we're like making the bulk of the
decisions of what content gets created
and who creates it not not me personally
but I mean just the group of people
working in the distribution game I don't
think there's enough of that focused on
in film school at all
um I'm not sure why that is I am sensing
because the introduction to Media
distribution book has been adopted at a
couple of universities
um and it's we're getting a second
edition of it like it's getting some
traction and I think that that is
growing
but it's you got to understand
distribution and I think that was the
thing that I wish I knew I I will say
this I I when I first came out to LA I
like thought I was like
I thought I had it all figured out and I
just like it I had no idea what I was
doing when I got here and like
everything I thought I knew was wrong
and I could not figure out
how does this industry work I couldn't
figure it out and it wasn't until years
later I took my first what would be my
first distribution job and I took it
because I just needed a job because it
was like I was working on movie sets
doing lighting work and it was
inconsistent and it was either go back
to waiting tables in between jobs or go
get a real adult job so I did the latter
I got a real adult job and it turned out
to be a sales job in the business and I
I was I didn't even know you could sell
TV shows or movies and that all of a
sudden once I learned that process
everything started to make sense about
how the industry works and that's when I
started going to cam that's when I
started going to all these markets and
all of a sudden I was on that side of
the table and I mean I was a production
assistant on my first movie and
I I was just dabbling project to project
a project and then uh just a couple of
years later I was in can and the
director of that movie was pitching me a
story so it's like it does it's it's so
the distribution thing is so critical in
terms of like that is the filter where
the whole industry crisscrosses through
that is the intersection
very long-winded way of saying I wish I
knew about distribution in film School